vize-kanzler robert habeck superminister
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz
angekommen auf dem vorläufigen höhepunkt
seiner politischen karriere ja und hier
stellt er gestern sein klimaplan vor und
beginnt mit der erkenntnis die
energiewende steht auf der kippe das
muss enormes tempo gemacht werden um die
ziele zu erreichen die folge gegenwind
von allen seiten einerseits von
klimaschützern denen die pläne nicht
weit genug gehen wirtschaftsverbände
wiederum fragen wer soll das bezahlen
der superminister zwischen allen fronten
oder anders gesagt hau für habeck und
stellvertretend für diese zwei fronten
sind uns jetzt zugeschaltet journalist
alexander kissler von der neuen zürcher
zeitung und der unternehmer army organi
hallo an sie beide
schicken morgen einen drastischen
rückstand beim klimaschutz will robert
habeck mit einem sofortprogramm konnten
gestern legte der wirtschaftsminister
seine pläne da was kommt auf deutschland
zu herr kessler
naja spricht er selbst zu einer großen
gigantischen transformation die in alle
gesellschaftlichen bereiche eingreifen
werde und das ist auch so also wie
werden eigentlich keine gefangenen mehr
gemacht sollen 100.000 neue e
ladestationen pro jahr hinzu kommen pro
jahr auf jedes neue dach von firmen soll
eine goldanlage kommen bei privaten
nicht zwingend aber doch die regeln
seien und es wird vor allen dingen etwas
stattfinden was man heute eigentlich nur
als ambitioniert oder sogar tollkühn
bezeichnen soll bis 2030 soll der anteil
der regenerierbaren energien der
energiebahnen energieträger auf 80
prozent ansteigen ich habe meiner cook
gestern abend war es 25 festnahmen kam
also in deutschland 25 prozent unseres
energiebedarfs aus regenerierbaren
quellen im schnitt waren es im letzten
jahr gut 40 prozent und das soll sich
nun verdoppeln oder vervierfachen
innerhalb von weniger als einem
jahrzehnt das ist eine wirklich hoch
hoch riskante wette und es kann sein
dass gesellschaft die wirtschaft einen
sehr hohen preis zahlen werden er
organisiert sind nicht nur unternehmer
sondern auch wirtschaftsingenieur in der
fachrichtung umwelt management welche
note würden sie habeck sofortprogramm
geben
also ich würde die note für den haag im
kontext der bisherigen minister
darstellen damit auch eine referenz für
die zuschauer ist es und da würde ich
sagen wenn ich die 16 jahre zurückgeht
hat der minister röttgen damals eine 5 -
verdient danach ruhig seine sechs
gabriel ebenfalls eine 5 und altmaier
eine 6 und habe ich jetzt eine zweite
warum weil ich der meinung bin dass die
bisherigen minister in den letzten 16
jahren gar kein ausbauplan oder
ausbauziel hatten vielmehr ging es darum
den ausbau zu verhindern und
möglicherweise auch zu reduzieren
deutlich geringeren maßen voranzubringen
ich habe aber das gefühl dass er mit
diesem vorstoß das was notwendig ist und
zwingend erforderlich ist umsetzung
einiges was in den letzten jahren wie
das was liegen geblieben ist aufholen
muss hat keine einfache aufgabe
und vor dieser herausforderung oder er
steht würde ich ihm auf jeden fall eine
zwei geben man auch mit einer neuen
haltung und wirklich mit einem
gesamtplan jetzt daran geht und die
vorgaben des bundesverfassungsgerichts
dann auch in den kontext gesetzt die
koalitionsvereinbarung umsetzt und ich
habe im gegensatz zu ihnen heute früh
interesse durchaus auch vom bdi positive
rückmeldungen bekommen minister banzer
energiewirtschaft positive rückmeldung
bekommen also so negativ wie sie es
vorhin dargestellt habe mich heute früh
nicht gelesen
nun haben die grüne auf den ruf
realitätsfern zu sein ist das
sofortprogramm denn praktikabel heck ist
dann möchte ich eben ein ganz ganz
großes fragezeichen dran machen ich habe
eben schon gesagt verdoppelung oder
vervierfachung der regenerativen
energien bis 2030 dann diese enorme wie
man schön sagt verspargelung der
landschaft also mit zahlreichen neuen
windrädern abstandsregeln sollen
teilweise verringert werden abstands
grenzen es soll offenbar ein super
durchgriffsrecht geben dadurch dass es
eben ein besonderes ein überragendes
öffentliches interesse haben soll also
auch gericht sollen leichter zu gunsten
von von ge von ausweisungen von regionen
entscheiden sollen auf den eben
photovoltaik und windräder entstehen
sollen er sagt diese ganze
transformation muss eine küchen
tauglichen debatte werden das hat
allerdings auch an ein streit über die
kosten dieser klimapolitik soll und wird
nun auch an den küchentisch einziehen
und die haben jetzt schon eine eine sehr
erhitzt die gesellschaft und sollte sich
herausstellen dass es eben nicht so
läuft wie gehabt gibt es vorstellt dann
werden wir auf diesem feld also neue
große gesellschaftliche konflikte
erleben jani wenn es nach
wirtschaftsminister habe gebe sollen bis
zum jahr 2030 80 prozent des benötigten
stroms durch wind oder sonne erzeugt
werden bislang lag die zielmarke bei 65
prozent ist das machbar oder eher
augenwischerei was meinen sie
also technisch ist es auf jeden fall
machbar wir haben in den letzten jahren
wir sehen dass weltweit global eine
unglaubliche exponentielle dynamik in
dem ausbau erneuerbaren energien
stattfindet das ist keine frage der
grünen mir also ich würde davor warnen
immer wieder das thema in blumen in die
schuhe zu schieben wir sind im globalen
wettbewerb und die länder mit china usa
japan im hirn all diese länder bauen
massiv in eurer energien aus und ich
dadurch einen wettbewerbsvorteil dahin
geht dass sie nicht auf die rohstoffe
aus russland oder aus den arabischen
staaten angewiesen sind und diesen
vorteil erarbeiten wir uns dadurch auch
denn wenn sie sich erst mal die
energiepreise der letzten monate
anschauen ist es auch ein ergebnis der
fossilen energieversorgung und sondern
will kriegen wir kostenlos liefert wir
müssen und investitionen der anlagen
zahlen für die brennstoffe zahlen
wenigstens also es wird deutschland
langfristig auf jeden fall den wohlstand
sichern viele arbeitsplätze schaffen und
für die haushalte gibt es auch eine gute
nachricht ab kommendem jahr wird es im
durchschnitt etwa 300 euro entlastung
geben dadurch dass das eeg künftig über
den steuer haushalt und nicht mehr über
die umlage der verbraucher abgerechnet
herr kessler was glauben sie wird die
bevölkerung den mit zehn robert habeck
hat gestern gesagt das was wir im
momentan beispielsweise an windrädern
sehen sind 0,5 prozent der fläche
deutschlands aber zwei prozent der
fläche deutschlands werden benötigt um
die energiewende zu schaffen da kann man
sich vorstellen wie viel da noch dazu
kommen muss viele sagen natürlich aber
nicht in meinem vorgarten
glauben sie dass die bevölkerung mitgeht
das ist genau die entscheidende frage es
gibt ja auch schon widerstand
aus bayerischen regierung beispielsweise
aber auch von naturschutzverbänden die
sich mit dieser aus ihrer sicht
verschandelung der natur nicht
einverstanden zeigen möchten ich bin es
auch nicht ganz so optimistisch was man
vorredner angeht was die energiekosten
angeht wir sind gerade aus china indien
russland angeht dass das auch in kohle
und uran kraftwerke investiert wird es
werden kosten auf den einzelnen auch zu
kommen auch durch die energetische
bausanierung das gibt es nicht zum
nulltarif werden alle dafür zahlen haben
und zu zahlen haben und frau berg hat
dem letzten jahr gesagt das fand ich
ganz interessant transformationen ist
eine mammutaufgabe die uns als
gesellschaft einiges zumuten wird man
wird diese zumutung befürchte ich eben
auch im portemonnaie spüren und auch
teilweise in
auseinandersetzungen vor ort man kann es
natürlich nur wünschen dass das alles
gut läuft aber ich bin der momentan
wirklich sehr skeptisch inhalte teile
der ziele für überambitioniert er
organisiert haben gerade angesprochen
dass wir uns natürlich mit diesem plan
unabhängig machen wollen von unseren
nachbarländern von anderen ländern damit
deutschland eben die stromversorgung
selber sicherstellen kann glauben sie
dass die maßnahmen ausreichen werden
wir sind auf jeden fall auf dem
richtigen wege und die frage ist nur was
ist die alternative sollen wir das
richtige system beibehalten und unsere
klimaschutzziele
nicht erreichen das ist ja keine
alternative also ich erwarte von jedem
der das kritisiert dass auch ein
alternatives konzept auf dem tisch liegt
und so ein wie bisher weiterzumachen
wäre ein irrsinniger weg ist er die
sackgasse wie gesagt also klar ist dass
auch die anderen länder mit atomkraft
und kohle kraftwerke weiterhin ihre
energieversorgung ausbauen aber der
anteil erneuerbarer energie ist deutlich
größer als die anderen energieträger und
die energie gestehungskosten über solar
und wind inzwischen die günstigsten
energiequellen auch in deutschland unter
diesen klimatischen bedingungen die wir
hier haben also ich würde jedem
empfehlen macht mein vorredner sich die
kosten und die zahlen genauer
anzuschauen das ist nicht in ordnung der
mann energien als teuer darzustellen es
ist eine transformation aufgabe 75
prozent der bevölkerung wünscht sich die
energiewende und dann müssen wir auch
handeln und nach unsere wirtschaft für
die zukunft
sie haben in dem wir uns was die
energieversorgung was aber auch die
produkt erneuerung produkt
transformationen angeht auf
klimaneutrale kinderfreundliche produkte
uns viel entwickeln ansonsten werden als
exportnation in den nächsten jahren
unsere produkte auf den globalen märkten
nicht mehr verkaufen können die academy
haben weil alternativprodukte aus usa
aus team aus anderen ländern in der lage
sind uns vor zu überholen schon zum mit
allen an den beruf noch passiert
herr kessler vielen dank für diesen
kleinen schlagabtausch und prügelt er
erweckt aber einstecken musste von
seiten der gäste waren natürlich nur
comichafte gemeint ganz herzlichen dank
für das gespräch und jetzt rechnen wir
es doch mal durch nina schenk ist bei
uns unsere kollegin was kosten die pläne
hallo thomas ja erst mal schön dass ich
bei euch beiden sein darf ja die pläne
sind schon ziemlich teuer das muss man
sagen ich kann das übrigens eben sehr
spannend zwischen herr rogan und heck
ist wenn man ja genau die diskussion
gesehen hat die wir gerade führen auch
auf einem sehr guten niveau die pläne
sind super teuer der klimawandel ist
selbstverständlich was ja auch herum gar
nie gesagt die größte herausforderung
unserer zeit aber wie teuer die pläne
von herrn haarwechsel das möchte ich
jetzt gerne mal mit euch teilen es sind
nämlich 50 milliarden kann man sagen
also und zwar hat der chef des
steuerzahlerbundes hab ich mal
mitgebracht die zahl reiner holznagel
hat heute in bild verkünden wir haben ja
auf seite eins ich fürchte auf uns wird
jährlich ein mittlerer bis hoher
zweistelliger milliarden betrag zukommen
ich gehe von einem höheren aus ich würde
80 milliarden sagen und er ist können
wir einmal runter rechnen also ganz
praktisch wir sind 80 millionen
bundesbürger kann man sagen 80
milliarden das heißt das wären pro kopf
wenn man so unterbricht einfach werden
es 1000 euro im jahr
solardach pflicht hat robert habeck ja
auch angesprochen würde ja verbraucher
was bedeutet das ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt dass da ich schätze auch dank der
fdp eine ganz gute lösung auf uns
zukommen könnte bei die solardach
pflicht soll in der regel erfolgen das
bedeutet aber nicht auf jedem dach also
sehr schwammig im koalitionsvertrag
ausgedrückt kann also bedeuten dass zb
industriegebäuden die pflicht kommt das
finde ich persönlich aber auch richtig
das heißt für neubauten neubauten sind
die pflicht bei industriegebäuden kommt
ich finde das persönlich sehr wichtig
ich finde sogar auch richtig der sache
aufgerüstet wird auf industriegebäuden
weil das ist nutzbar
wo ich sehr vehement dagegen bin und was
ich auch glaube was es mit der fdp als
koalitionspartner niemals geben wird ist
solardach pflicht auf jedem bau also auf
einfamilienhäusern da ist ja immer so
schreckgespenst kriegen wenn ihr
solardach pflicht auf den
einfamilienhäusern das glaube ich in der
koalition nicht deswegen wird auch
gesagt auf allen geeigneten dachflächen
will aber künftig solaranlagen
installieren also man muss jetzt nicht
um sein einfamilienhaus angst haben dass
morgen daran solardach drauf kommt die
sonne ist das eine der wind das andere
wir haben schon angeschaut die akzeptanz
ist dann nicht so groß wenn man selber
in der nähe eines windrads wohnt werde
diese pläne vom winde verweht sozusagen
die tun was jetzt kommen wir zu dem
punkt wo ich richtig temperatur drauf
habe und zwar ist es dass ich finde
nämlich schon das was habe ich da
vorgeschlagen hat man muss nicht jeden
einzelnen punkt kritisieren das ist aber
ein punkt den es für mich zu kritisieren
gilt es wurde eben schon angesprochen
auch von herr kessler wir wollen jetzt
auf 80 prozent ökostrom ökostrom wird
gewonnen aus wind- und aus solar das
bedeutet aber natürlich dass wir
windkrafträder ohne ende bauen müssen
ich wäre hier für windparks wo man am
ende sogar noch näher zum neuen träger
wasserstoff kommen könnte aber wie es
bei habe klingt ich hab's euch einfach
mal mitgebracht ich finde es ist man
merkt es dann mehr für den exzessiven
windkraftausbau b habe die bestehenden
abstandsregelung zwischen wohnbebauung
und windrädern verringern oder gar
abschaffen inhaber ex worten gehe es
etwa bei windkraftprojekten um
beeinträchtigungen der anwohner durch
emission sicht beschränkung oder
geräuschen würden diese schutzgüter
künftig nachrangig behandelt werden dann
kann auch zügiger genehmigt werden wenn
ich das jetzt mal plakativ ausdrücken
darf das ist eine teil enteignung des
bürgers weil er eigentlich völlig
irrelevant ist wie nah das windkraftrad
gebaut wird und deswegen muss ich sagen
muss da wirklich die grünen und auch er
habe müsste da mal wieder ein bisschen
realitätsnahe werden man kann nicht
einfach jeden bürger vor sein haus und
windkraft bauen vor allem wir auch da
die frage ist wie gut funktioniert das
auch als deswegen möchte ich pflegen
weil da hat herr organi recht immer nur
kritisieren ist schwach man muss ja auch
sagen wie wir den klimawandel schaffen
den gilt es zu schaffen ich wäre für
windkraftparks wo wir dann direkt auch
mehr haben ich bin für erneuerbare
energien aber nicht mit der gießkanne
aber die umsetzung die muss ja dann
natürlich auch realisierbar sein ja aber
er hat gesagt es fehlen so viel flächen
drei viertel der flächen die benötigt
werden die fehlen noch da muss er sich
da ein konzept überlegen es kann aber
nicht sein dass jeder bürger ein
windkraftrad vor die tür gebaut wird das
ist eine teilenteignung und ich glaube
schon dass man diese windkraftparks
umsetzen kann ich bin halt der feste
überzeugung die frage ist ja die wir uns
gerade stellen müssen wie praktikabel
ist es denn also ich möchte sich das
fass atomenergie aufmachen aber wir
müssen uns da schon ein bischen ehrlich
machen in der klimadebatte und deswegen
glaube ich auch dass es ökostrom konzept
so wie er sich das vorstellt nicht
funktionieren wird ich bin auch mal
gespannt ob seine koalitionspartner das
zulassen weil da geht es ja auch um den
artenschutz zum beispiel auch und ich
meine grünen ja stehen ja immer für
diversität und vielfalt ich finde das
sollten sie auch bei den windrädern
jetzt beachten da hat er eine ganz
witzige aussage gestern in den
tagesthemen gemacht wenn zwei prozent
der fläche also mit windrädern bebaut
wenn dann sind immer noch 98 prozent für
menschen und auf fledermäuse und kröten
da jedenfalls riesige herausforderung
und der spagat den habeck leisten muss
ist in der beschreibung seines ressorts
eben klimaschutz und wirtschaft
sozusagen schon angelegt dank für die
anordnung nena danke euch beiden